العالم يترقب محاكمه ترامب التاريخيه
ونيويورك تتاهب النيا تقارير امريكيه
البالون الصيني تجسس على مواقع حساسه ماسك
يستبدل عصفور تويتر بعمله دودج كوين
المشفره هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
يوم تاريخي تشهده الولايات المتحده حيث
يترقب العالم بدء محاكمه
في محكمه من هاتن بنيويورك بتهمن عده
ابرزها قضيه الممثله
امام المحكمه بساعات هاجمت القاضي اخوان
مرشان ووصفه بالخبيث كما يستعد بعد
الانتهاء من المحكمه لتوجيه خطاب لمناصريه
في فلوريدا فيما اظهرت استطلاعات للراي
تقدمه على منافسه المحتمل حاكم ولايه
فلوريدا بنسبه 57% مقابل 31%
في ملف محاكمه ترامب ايضا توعد الرئيس
الامريكي السابق المدعي العام في منهاتا
بانتقام قاسم حيث اخبر ترامب مستشاريه هو
المقربين منه بانه مستعد لتصعيد الهجمات
ضده وفقا للجارديون البريطانيه التي اضافت
ان الترتيب لهذا التصعيد ضد براج درسه
الرئيس السابق خلال اجتماعات استراتيجيه
مع مستشاري حول كيفيه الرد على لائحه
الاتهام من وجهه نظر قانونيه وسياسيه
وكانت ترامب قد اشار بالفعل الى انه
سيهاجم المدعي العام قبل اسابيع قائلا ان
النيابه كانت سياسيه بحته واتهم الفنبراج
بالمختل او ووصفه بالمختل عقليا
من امريكا واخبار ترامب الى خصم امريكا
الصين اذ عاد ملف بالون التجسس الصيني الى
الواجهه مجددا بعد ان كشف التقارير
امريكيه عن ان البالون جمع معلومات
استخباراتيه اثناء تحليقه فوق مواقع
عسكريه حساسه في الولايات المتحده وبحسب
وبحسب شبكه ام بي سي نيوز فان المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه التي جمعتها بكين كانت في
الغالب من الاشارات الالكترونيه الملتقطه
من انظمه الاسلحه في المقابل قال البيت
الابيض انه لا يمكنه تاكيد تقرير شبكه ام
بي سي الاخباريه لكنه لفتى الى ان واشنطن
حددت من قدره البالون
بعد لحظات من استبدال ايلون ماسك لوجو
تويتر بصوره كلب عمله
ارتفعت العمله الرقميه اكثر من 30% ووصلت
الى نحو 10.2 سنت من 7.7 سنت بعد التغيير
وعلى الرغم من ان تحركات ماسك على تويتر
لم تعد مفاجئه للعالم الا ان هذا الاعلان
اثار ردود فعل قويه في مجتمع العملات
الرقميه حيث اشار مستخدمون الى ان هذه
الخطوه تشير الى دعم ماسك للدوج كوين
الامر الذي قد يعزز من شعبيتها
في خبرنا الاخير تحديدا من اليابان حذر
احد المطاعم هناك استخدام الهواتف
المحموله اثناء التواجد بالمطعم تقارير
افادت بان صاحب المطعم
طبق قاعده شعبيه تدعو الزبائن لتناول
وجباتهم سريعا والمغادره فورا وذلك بعد ان
لاحظ ان بعض زبائنه يتاخرون في تناول
اطباقهم بسبب انشغالهم بمشاهده الفيديوهات
عبر هواتفهم المحموله واكد كايا انه لا
يضع اي لافتات في مطعمه تعلن حظر استخدام
الهواتف المحموله لانه يفضل ان يفعل ذلك
بنفسه والتحدث مع كل زبون بشكل منفرد